you will never guess what has happened  Robert Martin has offered me his hand do  you advise me I don't know the words  must be your own you must be the best  judge of your own happiness I have now  quite determined and really almost made  up my mind to refuse mr. Martin Emma mr.  Knightley this is your doing  she's the natural daughter of nobody  upon my word you should don't make  matters whatever you say  always comes to pass mr. Elton miss  Harriet Smith he's not with you who can  think of Miss Smith when miss Woodhouse  is near  [Music]  she always declares that she will never  marry I've no thoughts much money at  present which of course means just  nothing at all you must never be a  family  good heavens have I listed the party  he spent a whole day going to London  just to get his haircut is a trifling  silly [ __ ] they're here with whom will  you dance  mother you must sample the tart  [Music]  you